[Music]
welcome everyone I'm a whole monkey from
the android framework team and now can
send me a reveal some of the stuff I've
been working on and I'm Lucia from
Yunnan I'm an engineer on the AR and VR
team I'm actually going to start off by
telling you something very personal to
me and that I'm very passionate about
but it's not just one thing it's
actually a combination of things that I
love ever since I was a child I've been
marveled by space isn't it amazing just
think about it for a second
the diversity of the planets everything
that's going on around the solar system
right now wouldn't it be amazing if we
could just see it up close there's just
one problem though humans can't go to
another planet
not even Mars just yet or can we and
this starts the second part of my
passion augmented reality is delightful
it helps you interact in it with a world
that is within a whole new experience
that is catered to your environment
AR Corp is Google's platform for
augmented reality applications but even
if we use AR core to help us understand
the environment what do we do about 3d
rendering okay so while it's not exactly
rocket science
today 3d rendering has a steep learning
curve but if you're like me you're still
really passionate about space and AR and
3d and rendering and graphics and matrix
math so you just start coding and coding
and coding and coding and then you
quickly realize there's a lot of code
actually how many of you have written
OpenGL in their typical life so first of
all I'm so sorry
and second of all you party know how
difficult it is I've been doing this
kind of stuff for basically ten years at
Google and it's a pain proves my point
right here it's difficult and we've
noticed that there's so much in common
throughout all AR apps things like
streaming the camera image to the
background or even just making an object
appear on the screen so we wanted to
take care of that so you don't have to
go through all the pain no I go through
the pain that's why we built the scene
form SDK to make air development quick
simple and familiar to any Android
developer scene form is a 3d framework
that makes it easy for you to build a
our core apps it includes an Android
studio plugin that allows you to import
view and even edit 3d models the API
offers a high-level way of working with
3d and it's tightly integrated with AR
core so it makes it especially easy to
build a our apps because it integrates
with the Android view framework you can
easily add a R into an existing app or
create one from scratch
the New York Times you've seen form in
their new AR articles you can download
the New York Times app today and search
for our augmented reality and not only
read about David Bowie but also walk
around a mannequin wearing his costumes
Auto the online furnishing retailer
you've seen for him to allow customers
to see what a piece of furniture looks
like in their living room before they
buy it if you're from a European country
you'll be able to download the app and
try it out and actually a couple of the
engineers from o2 are in the audience
somewhere and I just want to thank them
because they were very patient with us
when we were working on syn form they
went through all the early versions of
the API you know it wasn't always
working right so thank you thanks for
your patience thanks for helping us
build it yes yeah I'm gonna play this
video again because I love it remember
that solar system I was talking about
that I wanted to bring to you here it is
right inside your living room and trust
me without the thousands of lines of
rendering code you can see this code
online right now by going to our github
repo repo linked at the end of the
presentation so let's walk through how
we built this app so first we'll start
off with some common concepts of AR apps
and then show you code snippets using
scene form after we've covered the
basics Ramon will go into detail about
physically-based materials and give you
all sorts of rendering knowledge to help
you optimize and make beautiful 3d
objects and your app the C form API
consists of two concepts the scene and
the view the scene represents the
objects you are adding to the world like
through 3d models that you want to place
in your AR app the view is where your
scene will be drawn in this case it's
your device screen and where the device
is in the world the render will draw the
scene
from this perspective the view ties into
the Android view framework our system
and that's your hook into the app as a
developer you will build your scene by
defining the spatial relationships of
objects to do this scene form provides a
high-level scene graph API for defining
the hierarchy of objects on their
spatial relations relationships one
analogy that I like to think about is
the Android view hierarchy but instead
of obviously in 3d and instead of views
we use graph nodes each node contains
all the information that scene form
needs to render it and to interact with
it and finally nodes can be added to
other nodes forming a parent-child
relationship in our solar system example
planets orbit around the Sun and moons
of these planets orbit around the planet
a natural way to define this the define
the solar system in a scene graph is to
make the Sun the root node and add
planets as a Suns children and add the
moons as their children that way if you
want to animate the earth orbiting the
Sun the moon will just follow the earth
you don't have to do the complicated
math to figure out the moon's
relationship to the Sun while the earth
is orbiting it in this video it's the
same solar system example that we saw a
little bit ago but we've also added
touch interaction nodes can become
interactive by adding touch listeners to
them obviously and we propagate touch
events through the scene graph the same
way Android touch events are propagated
through the view hierarchy notes can
contain 3d models like the planets or
the Sun or 2d Android views you can
create an Android view just as you would
and your layout editor and put it in the
world and interact with it like you
would with any other app
it's a first-class citizen of our scene
so how does an Android developer usually
get started with Android studio of
course I won't go too deep into this
because there is another talk tomorrow
morning called build iterate and launch
that will show you all of these steps
but I want to note that we have built a
plugin for Android studio that allows
you to drop in 3d models that are built
with standard modeling tools like Maya
or you can download them from Pali you
go through the import flow and that
converts the models into an SFA and SFB
format these formats are particular to
scene form and the SFA is what's bundled
into your app so drop the SFA file into
the reservoir folder or the source
assets folder and you can ship it with
your app one thing we wanted to note yes
you can view and edit your models right
there in Android studio and what's
important to note is that we use the
same rendering renderer on the device
and inside Android studio so what you
see in studio will be what you see on
the device one other thing to note again
there will be more details tomorrow the
importer acts as a Gradle plugin so for
every asset that you import inside your
projects are going to get a new Gradle
task which means that if your designers
give you a new version of the assets all
you have to do is replace the file in
your project the next time you build we
will recover the asset automatically and
you'll be up to date so you don't have
to worry about going through a manual
wizard every time you get a new version
of the asset let's start coding yeah
let's start off with our on create
method in your activity - Suzy would
find the AR fragment find scene forms
they are in fragment this takes care of
setting up the AR core session for you
and also manages the lifecycle of scene
form and naturally it will contain the
AR view
and the view holds a reference to the
scene I want to note here that you don't
have to use our fragment you can use the
view and therefore the scene directly
and this is one of the powerful things
about sin form because it's just using a
regular or Android view that happens to
be a surface view you can drop it
wherever you want in your application it
doesn't have to be full screen and more
importantly we don't take over your
application if you try to something you
like unity for instance unity becomes
your application it's a very easy way to
embed a are inside an Android
application that already exists and New
York Times for instance is a great
example of how far you can push this
because they show AR through a webview
so they just put in their view behind a
transparent webview and as you scroll
the webview the load contents into the
AR you so you can do pretty complex
things it isn't it to be just a simple
fullscreen example like you're seeing
here so let's start loading all of our
models and in this case I have a to do
for you to wrote the load the rest of
them but I'll show you how to build a 3d
model in scene form we have two types of
models we call or not model sorry render
bowls renderable czar the things that
are going to be rendered on the screen I
know we're very creative with the naming
in this case we want to load the Sun
model which was dropped into our res raw
folder and so you set those source and
build I also want to point out that
these are completable futures so it will
do the loading in the background and you
can accept and handle as you would with
a completable future I should also
mention Kotlin here we could do all of
this in Kotlin but all of the code
snippets will be in Java one thing we
haven't done yet is build cut in
extensions for a scene form but if you
are inclined to do so I would love to
see your code so remember earlier we
showed you this graph representing the
Sun and the planets
keep the structure in mind because we're
going to be loading and creating the
scene graph we've loaded all the models
so now let's build a solar system
we start off with the Sun node create a
new gnome and set its renderable to be
the Sun model that you had loaded next
we create the earth node we set its
parent to the Sun therefore building the
scene graph starting to build a scene
graph notice here that I have set the
Sun to earth meters constant I in this
case I've used 0.5 meters because I
wanted to fit the solar system inside
the living room but we've set the
Earth's local position relative to its
parent the Sun set the render bowl that
we loaded continue now the moon create
the node set the parent to Earth and
notice here now that this the local
position of the moon is earth to moon
and meters I think I've set it to be 0.1
it has nothing to do with the Sun set
the renderable as a moon renderable and
you're set now to animate their orbit
you can just use androids property
animation system we've created some
evaluators for you to use once we return
the root node we now have the entire
graph our solar system so let's bring
the solar system into the scene all we
have to do is parent it to the scene and
that's it the or parent the signs of the
scene and the solar system is now in
your room or we could do something else
anchors I don't know if you know about a
arc or anchors but they are how you
attach your content to the world and a
arc or make sure that they are anchored
to the world you can get anchors from AR
cores hit tests based on the user's
touch events or with our new cloud
anchors you can use an anchor that
another friend has created on another
device for using anchors we've created
an extension to node called the anchor
node that just takes an anchor and now
brings that anchor
into our scene graph set the anchor
nodes parent easily just to the scene
and then set the son's parent to the
anchor node notice how we've rearranged
it a little bit first we have a scene
with a son as a root node but now we've
created the scene the anchor node and
then the son and the rest of the solar
system I was mentioning modeled render
holes before so now we'll talk about the
2d view render bowls to add 2d into your
app in this case I've used a little info
card that pops up about a quarter of a
meter above a planet say and you you
want it to display some information on
it so I've created this node that would
hold the view renderable I've set it to
a planet and it will now float a quarter
of a meter above the planet wherever
that planet is you start off by building
a view renderable but notice here that
instead of the res raw source for the
model renderable I've set it to the view
ID and that's all there is to it now you
have the 2d view just as you would have
in any other application and you could
do things with that view like set the
text and finally if you want to drag
scale and rotate objects we've made that
really easy for you by creating a
transformable node the transformable
node is an extension to node but it also
understands touch events and gestures
like dragging and scaling and rotating
objects so in this case if instead of
creating a Sun node I created a
transformable Sun node I would just do
everything else that I did before but
now we can actually drag and move the
roll the solar system I should mention
that there is there was a talk earlier
today about UX interactions in AR so if
you want to know more about the best
practices for us please go back and look
at bad talk
let's talk about materials so this is a
this evening simple part of sin form but
before we can understand how to create
your own material we have to understand
the concept between behind physically
based rendering so after your important
asset through the inroads to a plug in
like Lucy said you end up with two files
this dude at SFA and the dot sfv so the
dot s FB is the binary that goes into
your application and that will load at
runtime the dot SFA is effectively a
JSON description of the asset it looks a
little bit something like this so this
is the SFF from the the moon or the moon
of the earth that from our example and
you can see those attributes called base
color
normal and metallic roughness so those
point two textures that are defined
somewhere else in the SFF file I'm not
going to go into details about the
syntax and the structure of the SFF file
mostly because there's excellent
documentation that's available online is
also to talk tomorrow morning so you
should check that out but what I want to
talk about is what do we what what kind
of textures do you need to create to be
meaningful for the color the normal and
those two-wheeled ones the metallic and
the roughness textures but again before
we do this we have to talk about
physically based rendering so obviously
physically based rendering started
becoming quite popular over the past I
would say three or four years it's
starting the VFX in the streets now you
know a lot of triple-i games it's still
fairly uncommon on mobile and the basic
idea behind it is that we are relying on
physical principles to define all the
behaviors and all the equations that you
will use in the rendering system so that
includes things like separating the
lighting code from the the code that
defines the surface and that has an
impact on the materials themselves it
means that we have to take into account
laws of physics like the energy
conservation we use physical light units
so constants when we declare a Sun as a
dynamic light machine we use the
called Lux or he were to add a light in
your scene in your AR scene that's just
the light bulb you can use what or
lumens as the unit so it's a number of
things like this that are branding a
reality that both help us validate our
rendering it also makes our life easier
because those are things we deal with
every day and that feel natural to us
I'm gonna show you an example so this is
an example it's not in AR but this has
been rendered using our rendering engine
just a very simple sphere and you can
see that there are reflections on the
sphere you can see what you are seeing
here in action is a physical in fact
called a final effect after a 19th
century physicist and the closer you are
to the edge of the sphere the more you
can see the reflections and this is a
natural phenomenon that you can see
everywhere so this is a photo I took in
Lake Tahoe and you can see that close to
the edge where I was standing you can
see through the water and the further
away you get the more you can see the
reflections of the water so and again
you can see this on every object every
object around you follows this principle
might not be obvious at first but this
is what happens and we recreate this
kind of physical behaviors in our
rendering engine to make things looks
look as realistic as possible so we
follow a workflow format shows called
the metallic roughness workflow if you
look that up you're gonna see there's a
lot of information out there
the metallic roughness workflow is
available in a lot of popular tools
if you've used unity 5 you have access
to it Unreal Engine 4 uses it blender
recent versions has access to some
metallic work through as well so the way
it works is when you want to define a
new material you are actually trying to
describe and define a surface and to
define a surface you're gonna need three
things and we're going to take them in
this order for very specific reasons
we're going to explain them in a little
bit the first one is you need to define
the metallic property of the surface
often we talk about metallic Ness but
it's not even a word so metallic no at a
high level is whether object whether or
not the object is a metal and
gonna see why this is very important to
us then you're going to define the color
of the object and we call it the base
color as opposed to the diffuse color or
the specular color those up terms that
you might have seen if you've used other
engines and again there's a reason for
that
finally you need to define something
called a roughness
roughly it means how shiny the object is
and if you want to go further there are
two other things you can define to give
your just refers your surface more
detail more details a more natural
appearance so the first one is the
normal or the normal map it just helps
break the evenness of the surface and
the second one is called the ambient
occlusion or occlusion so first what is
a non-metal I'll spare you the equation
this is actually fairly simple so here
at the bottom we have an object an
orange object it's drawn in ingria to
make the diagram easier to read but we
have light coming from a light source
and hitting the surface of the object
and the the the light that hits the
object gets split into two components
the first one in white is the reflected
part so those are all the reflections so
in that orange ball that we saw before
at the edges you could see those
reflections that's the that's the part
of the light and then the other part of
the light is refracted in through the
object and most objects around us they
absorb some of the light the light
enters the object it gets scattered it
bounces around inside the object and
even some of the light will come out but
not all of it and this is what gives
object colors in that particular case
because the object appears orange it
just means that green and blue
components of the light have been
absorbed inside the object and that
orange light that comes out is called
the diffused light the white light is
for the specular light so specular is
for the reflections and diffuse is for
everything else so this is an example of
a non metallic orange ball and you can
see those reflections if you look at the
reflections here this is simulating an
environment inside the classroom where
we have overhead
white lights and you can see that even
though the object itself is orange the
lights appear white that's because they
just bounce off they don't enter the
object they don't take the two
take the color of the object into
account and then the rest of the object
the non reflective parts are arranged as
expected now when you have a metallic
object metals are conductors and they're
called conductors because when energy
hits them in this case lights the lights
the part of the energy that's refracted
into the surface gets absorbed it just
gets transmitted into the object and
does not get scattered outside so
there's no diffused light
you only get reflections however what
happens with those reflections is that
they get detect the color of the object
so you don't get those white reflections
anymore you get the orange reflections
instead so if we take the same ball that
we just saw and we turn it into a Meno
if you look again at the lights at the
overhead lights of that classroom you
can see that they now appear orange and
this is because the rest of the light
arised the rest of the specular light
was absorbed inside the object you can
also see another side effect of this of
the phenol law that we just talked about
if you look at the edges of the sphere
you can see that the reflections are not
orange anymore they take on the color of
the environment this is again a very
natural effect it feels weird when you
Street for the first time in a rendering
engine but rendering engineers like me
who are obsessed about their work comes
Christmas time they look at the
Christmas tree and they take a picture
of one of the ornaments
I was holding one of my phones on the
side I was lighting the this green metal
ball with an orange light from the
wallpaper on my phone and you can see
that on the edge of the ball certainly
the reflections are not green anymore
they take on the orange light coming
from their light source so what we just
saw here can you keep weird when you sit
on the computer for the first time but
this is an effect that's perfectly
natural that happens everywhere around
you so the metallic property I mentioned
that this is the first thing you should
decide and you know Stan why because
when you define the color of your object
when you find the base color is whether
or not depending on whether or not your
object is metallic or not it's gonna
dramatically change the aspect of the
surface so you should always decide
first whether you're dealing with metal
or nonmetal so when it comes time to
create the actual texture the metallic
Ness of the object
we defined as a grayscale texture so
values between 0 and 255 at 0 the object
is not a mental and at 255 when it's
white the object is a metal most of the
time the value should be either 0 or
either 1 all the values in between are
mostly used for anti design purposes
because you know your your texture could
contain maybe it's a metal that's
painted and the paint itself is not a
metal so the edges of the paints you
want nice fall off nice transitions from
metal to nonmetal certain alloys in real
life happens to be a mixture and you can
use intermediate values as well but most
of the time you won't have to deal with
it you won't have to worry about it very
quickly when a metal gets rusty it
actually becomes nonmetallic so if
you're trying to create a surface that's
rusty the the rush stains will be
nonmetal yeah oh and very often so
that's something that again you'll see
tomorrow you don't have to use textures
for everything you can also use
constants and very often you can get
away with not having a texture for the
metallic Ness of your object you can
just say either it's a metal or it's not
ok next step you have to define the base
color so the color of your object it
defines either the diffuse color of the
object for non metals or the specular
color or the color of the reflections
for metallic objects and what's quite
difficult to do when you create a base
color texture is that it must be
completely devoid of any lighting
information or any shadowing and we're
going to look at an example that can be
hard because as human beings we never
see the actual color of an object we
only see objects through lighting so
it's difficult to imagine what it looks
like but you can quickly get used to it
and whenever you use a tool like
Photoshop or affinity photo to build
your textures make sure that you're
working in the sRGB color space and
which is what this tool should be doing
by default but just in case make sure
you and your artists work in that color
space so this is a quick guide of how to
build colors for objects based on
real-world data most of non metallic
objects use most of the range of the
brightness so whenever you pick a color
in the color picker for a nonmetallic
objective values of your
the colors between 10 and 240 and
there's nothing as dark as zero there's
nothing as bright as 255 when when we
deal with nonmetals and mellows on the
other hand they're always fairly bright
so they are not dark metals basically
don't exist so you should stay in the
range that's shown up here now it's
mentioning that you should not have any
lighting information inside your the
base color of the object and you can see
here a set of swatches taken from real
world observation and you can see that
gold for instance that in real life
appears quite yellow and saturated the
base color is actually not that
saturated all the colors in the base
color map tend to be very pale compared
to what you actually perceive so here's
another example on the right you can see
a material of to represent bricks and on
the left you can see the base color
texture and you can see the difference
once we light the object all the
contrast and saturation appears but all
that information is not in the original
texture that we're using to create this
material so again if you work with your
artist make sure they are familiar with
the metallic the metallic roughness
workflow or make sure that it is
understand that the base column
absolutely should not contain any
lighting or shadowing now I mentioned
this the third parameter is called a
roughness and defines how xiangjian
objectives so a very simple way to
define a surface is like this it's
infinitely smooth there is no object in
the world that stays smooth and what
happens when you have a smooth object
light rays of light that are coming
parallel to each other bounce of
parallel to each other as well so you
get very sharp reflections rough objects
on the other hand have what we call
macro facets at the surface you can
think of those as very very tiny mirrors
that may not be oriented in the same
directions so when light comes in you
have this parallel rails rays of light
they can bounce off in random directions
and that causes the creates blurry
reflections and those are examples at
the top you can see a ball a yellow
metal
and we increase the roughness from zero
all the way to one and at the bottom we
have a non metallic ball and we increase
the roughness from zero to one and you
can see the effect here we start with
very sharp reflection and as we get
closer and closer to one the reflections
become so blurry that we can't even
perceive that there are reflections they
are there but they're spread over
basically the entire surface the entire
visible surface so this is a very
powerful feature because it lets you
again create things like polished metals
or you know a plastic that has been used
for for quite a while and it's become
well basically rough so roughness is
very similar to the metallic property
it's a grayscale texture use values
between 0 and 255 at zero your surface
is going to be glossy or very shiny at
255 can be extremely rough and I'm going
to be able to see the reflections
anymore and just be aware that there may
be differences between different tools
so if you specify a roughness of 100
let's send blender that some roughness
might look a little bit different in a
different engine because there are
different ways of doing those
computations you shouldn't worry too
much about this just 3d asset the asset
and so it looks right instead of sim
form sometimes the roughness will be
called glossiness instead and glossiness
is just the opposite value so you can
just invert the texture in Photoshop for
instance to get the roughness map next
we want to add some details so to save
on performance and memory we try to use
smooth surfaces so when you build your
mesh made of triangles you use smooth
surfaces so here we have an example of
bricks that are completely smooth to add
some details we can use a normal map a
normal map looks like this when you
apply to the object suddenly you get a
little bit of of shadowing and more
information more details on the surface
I'm not that I go into too much details
about normal maps because there's a ton
of information with Elbon lines we're
gonna skip that before we run out of
time the only thing to know is that the
colors instead of normal a normal map
and could a vector it's a direction it's
not a color next one is ambient
occlusion so here we have a we have our
bricks and they've been texture properly
the roughness that we metallic the
normal map but we're like in what we
call macroscale shadowing information
because a brick has a depth so it will
create shadows on itself like the
surface should be casting shadows on
itself but because we don't have access
to the triangles instead what we creates
is just a black and white texture that
tells us where the shadows should be so
again that's called ambient occlusion or
occlusion it's very simple - oh sorry
let's do it before and after that's
after before after
so again adds a lot of detail and depth
to your object and the Myint illusion
map is just a grayscale texture when the
values are zero if the pixel is
completely in the dark you should never
have value set to exactly 2-0 at 255
there's going to be no shadowing and it
doesn't affect all the lighting I'm not
going to go into too much detail so
anytime you create an object that has
cracks or crevices that kind of stuff
you should be using an ambient occlusion
map so in the end we have our five
textures we have the metallic Ness the
best color the roughness the normal and
the mint occlusion and if you get them
all together in this particular example
you can create an object where
everything varies from pixel to pixel so
here we have a metal ball but for some
reason some of the tails are missing and
those are not metals anymore the
reflections out is gone
so you can see with just the three
textures you can create very impressive
variations from pixel to pixel and
create most real-world materials in the
photorealistic manner
one thing you can do to optimize your
materials especially if use the 3d
format called gltf that i'm sure they're
going to talk about more in details
tomorrow you can pack the channels into
a single texture so ambient occlusion
roughness and metallic nests are
grayscale images so they can each fit in
one of the channels of an RGB image you
can do this easily in any good photo
editor like GIMP or affinity photo here
or Photoshop and you can have only one
texture instead of three it's gonna
speed up your load times going to speed
up the rendering as well alright so now
I want to talk about performance a
little bit so one of the features that
we have instead of our rendering engine
is something called dynamic resolution
what we do is we always watch the time
spent on the GPU to render every frame
and instead of dropping frames when
too much to render we adapt the
resolution of the of the rendering so we
smoothly added the resolution both on
the vertical and the horizontal axis
sometimes with that first one axis then
the other sometimes both at the same
time so what this means for you is that
if you're building and they are seen if
you make it too complicated if you have
too many objects if you have materials
that are too complex we're not going to
drop frames were always been a favored
performance over anything else but we
are going to lower the resolution of
your scene it works really well on our
phones because we have really high
density displays so it's really hard to
tell when this is going on and I'm sure
that most of you won't even notice as
you're using the app but basically it
boils down to do you want to see a
complex scene at lower resolution or do
you want to see a simple scene at higher
resolution the maximum resolution we
currently use is 1080p even on devices
like the pixel to excel we're not going
to use the full resolution of the
display because it's just way too many
pixels to be able to drive physically
based rendering I want to call out that
the render does this automatically yes
it's done automatically you don't have
to worry about it we take care of
performance in this case mesh is when
you create your objects it can be really
tempting especially for your artist to
create to add a lot of triangles to
create fully smooth surfaces but we're
running all of this on mobile phone so
you should be careful with the
complexity of the objects to give you a
rough idea what we call a hero object so
an object you can get really close to
should have maybe at most 10,000
triangles but even that if you can avoid
using that mini triangles it would be
great and if use 10,000 triangle in one
object make sure there's only one of
them and not 100 of them otherwise
performance is going to suffer and this
is already with some of our early access
partner this is one of the common issues
that we've seen really tell your artist
to simplify the models as much as
possible and it's really important
because every time we have a triangle
that's smaller than the pixel the GPU is
gonna do way too much work I'm not gonna
go into the details here because you
probably don't care but basically we
might end up doing the work four times
and we really don't want to do that the
complexity of the scene thankfully in
the eye you're probably not gonna add a
lot of objects but you favor create and
they are seen for instance where you
have a model of a city you might be
tempted to put a lot of objects in that
city you know every building or every
car every even pedestrian what we
recommend is that at most you should
have maybe a hundred objects visible at
a time on screen and the reason here is
because we're gonna run into the CPU is
going to become a bottleneck so this is
not something that dynamic resolution
can help with we avoid rendering
anything that's not on the screen we
have a lot of optimizations around that
but if we have too many objects on
screen we're gonna be bound by the CPU
and there's not much we can do about it
and you're gonna start dropping frames
and dropping frames is partly by bad in
they are I mentioned the format called
gltf we support obj and FBX the LCF is a
new is a standard driven by Chronos
Chronos is the the committee behind
opengl and invoke in a lot of tools
supported CF websites like sketchfab
have a lot of assets in the gif format
and one of the reasons why I like GL CF
is because in the standard they pack the
occlusion
the roughness and the metallic inside a
single RGB texture which is something
you should be doing for performance
reasons so if you connect ask your
artists to give you gif models it's
going to make by default your models or
your more efficient to render one thing
we didn't show you how to do with the
idea is you can add lights in your sin
and you can add many many many many
lights this is an example of an early
demo of our rendering engine running on
my pixel - so here I think we had
something like 128 lights in the scene
so you can see that you can you can have
many many of them and we can still run
at 60 frames per second what's very
important is that if you add many lights
in your scene make sure they don't
overlap or that they don't overlap too
much because if we have two lights on
the same thing so we have to do the work
twice so if you have you know 100 lights
on one pixel we're basically running one
frames so use a lot of lights if you
want make sure they don't overlap and to
do this in IPS you can give us a maximum
sphere of influence for each light
finally if you use the view run rebels
it's extremely convenient you can create
views the way you do it in the rest of
your application you can put them in the
scene super useful but every view is
rendered in software and for every view
we have to allocate what's called its
surface texture and this is going to
cost memory it's going to cast CPU time
and it's going to cost GPU time so try
to reuse the views as much as possible
don't try to put too many of them on the
screen and not try to allocate too many
of them at the same time and finally all
the usual advice that we give you for
performance inside Android application
applies to a are obviously so don't
allocate in the render loop don't do too
much work be mindful of the size of your
apk and all that that good stuff with
that we're out of time there's a talk
tomorrow morning
build iterate and launch your apps
there's another one called designing a
applications that was earlier today yeah
today earlier this afternoon so come
back two hours ago we also have office
hours there's a code lab available
online to create a stimulus into what
you saw and that's it and if you have
questions you can find us after this
talk or tomorrow we'll be around to
answer all your questions
[Music]